if you've been trading for a while
you've probably felt stuck like no
matter what you do you keep running in
circles you put the work in you watch
the videos you tweak your strategy but
somehow you're still not making
consistent money that's because almost
every Trader falls into two dangerous
cycles and if you don't break out of
them they're going to continue draining
your time your money and your confidence
and the first one is the learning Loop
where you are stuck in research mode
constantly tweaking and never being
consistent with one specific strategy
and the second one I call the
self-sabotage Loop where you're now
consistently executing a strategy but
you're making emotional mistakes that
continuously wipe out your progress
these Loops can keep you spinning for
years blowing up accounts hesitating on
good trades and worst of all wasting one
thing you can't get back your time but
once you understand these loops and how
they work you can break free from them
and I know this works works because I've
had students stuck in these exact same
loops and once they realized that made a
few key tweaks they've been able to turn
their trading around and to help
accelerate your process of breaking
through these negative Loops I've put
together a list of 75 essential trading
lessons that I learned over my 7 plus
years of trading these are the
hard-earned lessons that helped me
excape these Cycles myself and they can
help you too you can get it for free by
clicking the link in the description or
scanning this QR code now let's get into
the meat of this and go through how
these two loops work and how you can
break free from them and first we're
going to start off with the most common
Loop that stops 95% of Traders from even
starting to become successful at trading
and I call it the learning Loop where
you are just learning and tweaking your
strategy so much that you never give
yourself time to actually start
practicing and becoming good at the
strategy the whole idea of how this Loop
works is you know however you're
learning content probably through
YouTube since you're here is you you
know you find a new strategy and you
know you start to learn new patterns you
learn my strategy and you start kind of
practicing it you test it out and it's
not really working for you you know you
maybe have some success initially you
know in the first week or two but over
time you're not getting those consistent
results over the long term right
and then from that point well you know
logically when you are learning anything
in the world it makes sense to go learn
more right because adding more
information and learning more
information usually makes you better at
something but when it comes to trading
there are infinite ways to actually
trade the market and so you are going to
overload yourself with information you
actually don't need a lot of information
to become successful at trading I've
always found found that simpler is
better and so what most people do and I
did this myself is I would say oh well
you know this strategy just doesn't work
and let me go find a new one or add you
know another indicator that helps
confirm my trades that will increase my
win rate and in reality that doesn't
really work you are essentially starting
over from square one now when you're
starting out and you're learning new
strategies it's important to go learn
about bunch of different strategies
because you don't know you know what
works with kind of your style and how
you want to trade and you're just
starting to learn but once you kind of
do that you got to really be aware that
you are going to be stuck in this cycle
really really easily if you don't stop
yourself from learning more and more
strategies and so how you break out of
this is committing to one strategy you
know over time what I realized was
simpler was better and I came came up
with kind of essentially this 30 minute
reversal strategy where I only trade 60
minutes a day roughly in the morning and
I look for one specific pattern I used
to try and think oh I can capture you
know every move in the market anytime
the r goes up that's a missed
opportunity every time it goes down
that's you know something I should have
been able to read into a pattern and
figure out that the market was going to
do that and I should have been able to
capture that move and make profit off of
that but instead
what I've realized over time is
executing the exact same strategy and
looking for a specific pattern every day
and waiting for that specific pattern is
way more profitable because you are
waiting for the market to fit you versus
trying to fit the market and that's
reactionary and that's not a profitable
way to trade and so for me I literally
look for this is just a bunch of
pictures of charts of Trades that I've
taken of saying I just look for the same
thing the Market opens for me
at this time I look to see if the market
has a big you know move in One Direction
and then I look for essentially a double
bottom in the market kind of 30 minutes
after the S&P 500 opens that's what I
trade I trade S&P 500 futures 30 minutes
after it opens I've realized that that's
kind of a timing where the market likes
to reverse and so if that lines up with
the market doing a double bottom that's
a really good Buy Signal for me and I
just repeat that over and over these are
all different days where you can see the
Market opens it spikes down it makes
essentially a double bottom there's a
nice big bullish Candlestick I buy above
that big Candlestick and it it fits that
same pattern every day and I wait for
that same pattern and if that pattern
shows up I take it and if it doesn't I
just move on with a day and it's able to
be very very repeatable and very simple
and this has helped me break out of that
cycle of trying to constantly find new
things because you can see every day is
slightly different you know sometimes
the market spikes up and I look for a
double top instead and bet the Market's
going to go down and sometimes it's just
choppy and there's no good trade or some
days it's just sitting there and does
nothing or Trends in One Direction
really fast and I get no trade and
that's okay you don't need to be making
money consistently every day to be a
consistently profitable Trader no
pattern or strategy is successful in
every Market condition what you want to
do is realize that what can I be
successful with and then focus and
narrow down on that start a trading
journal and start tracking your trades
and essentially mastering that one
strategy because that's what's going to
break you out of this Loop because
otherwise you're just starting from
square one all the time and you're just
going to be stuck in that cycle and I
was stuck in that cycle for years and
years and I know a ton of my students
are just the same and you got to
remember when it comes to what the
trading Journey looks like with any
strategy that you start out you're going
to start out losing money or just not
making any money at all even with a
strategy that you could be profitable
with in the future you're not going to
make money with it right away you're
going to be losing money because you're
going to need to start mastering that
strategy and also once you break out out
of that learning Loop and start focusing
and mastering one strategy it doesn't
mean you're just going to magically
start shifting your profit graph and
you're going to go up from there
actually what changes your chart to
becoming consistently profitable and
breaks you out of you know kind of
slowly losing money and becoming
consistently profitable with a strategy
is you're then going to get stuck in
what I call the self-sabotage Loop and
that's because you are going to start
executing and trying to consistently
match your trades like for example if
you're executing my strategy every day
you see this setup but all of a sudden
you know this happens and your strategy
says okay I need to buy but you get you
know scared and instead you don't take
that setup and you miss out on a
profitable trade or you jump in too
early like somewhere down here and the
market stops you out when it makes one
more push down while it's making that
double bottom and you get stopped out
when the market makes one more push down
confirming that double bottom that's
when you're starting to get fomo and so
the self- sabotage Loop comes from your
emotions and you negatively impacting
your ability to consistently properly
execute this strategy what allows you to
turn your profit graph to consistently
making money is learning how to actually
manage how your emotions negatively
impact your trading everyone is slightly
different they have different emotions
that will control their trading more
more but the idea is you know you have
either greed that makes you you know
jump into a trade too early take a loss
and that messes up how your strategy is
actually supposed to work or you have
fear of getting in a trade and so you
miss out on a profitable trade affecting
the results of how your training
strategy should actually work and so you
have to go in and think about what
emotions am I feeling and how they are
affecting my trade how does the
impulsivity that comes into me when I
feel fear or nervousness or I have fomo
which is the fear of missing out of you
know a potential trade how do I react
based on that the whole thing with
trading is you can feel all these
emotions I still feel all these emotions
but I don't let the emotions control me
that's the biggest thing when it comes
to trading is controlling your actions
how you want you don't have to be an
emotionless robot to be successful at
trading it's actually the opposite it's
you need to feel all these emotions but
learn how to react properly to them
change how you react to them and instead
of you know Revenge trading and taking
you know having massive blowup days or
weeks where you you know jump in uh
trades just based out of frustration you
instead stop yourself from doing that
and say hey I need to just be done with
trading for the day and move on reset
and come back the next day
and consistently wait for my pattern and
strategy to show up and so how you break
out of this is you have to kind of
figure out what your self- sabotage Loop
looks like and so to walk you through
what my self-sabotage Loop is so you can
kind of see how it works how it maybe
you know gives ideas to how yours works
and then we'll talk about how you can
break out of it and so how my self-
sabotage Loop was worked was I always
had a massive fear of being wrong with
my trades I was always scared that my
trade would not work you know that this
one time that I'm getting in the trade's
not going to work out even though
trading is it's like you're going to the
casino right you're it's all percentage
based you're not going to win every
trade logically I always knew yeah my
win rate could be 50% but I you know
make three times amount that I lose so
every time you know I lose a trade let's
say I lose $100 but every time I win a
trade I win $300 well at a 50% win rate
you're making consistent money over the
long term but when it comes down to
trading I would have kind of that narrow
tunnel vision would come in that fear
would kind of make me just Tunnel Vision
on this one trade and the fear would
overwhelm me and control my actions and
I would end up skipping the trade and
usually because you know for me most of
the time when I showed up to trading I
was dialed in focused waiting for my
strategy and a lot of times my read
would be pretty good I would notice that
that pattern and it was a good trade and
so I would end up skipping a good trade
skipping out on you know profits I would
then be frustrated because it was you
know it pissed me off that I missed a
profitable trade and I really should
have been in it I knew I should have
been in it I just got a little scared
hesitated and especially for me trading
on you know a smaller time frame like a
one minute chart things happen quickly
you have to take action right away you
can't kind of sit there on like on a
higher time frame and kind of let the
emotions kind of ease out a little bit
and you know jump in a lot of times by
the time you know I get over that
initial fear the trade would be gone you
know the market would have already you
know shot up in the favor of that
direction that I was thinking and it
would be too late so then you know I'm
frustrated I would continue to watch the
charts because you know I said well you
know maybe another setup will show up
right and so I would then fomo or
impulsively jump into a bad trade you
know it would start to set up or it
would you know I'd cut a few Corners
right like let's say I I have my fstep
entry checklist that I wait for every
time well instead you know I I get four
out of five and I say you know whatever
it's good enough I just missed a trade I
I got to get in here I'm not going to
miss another one and so I would jump in
you know with fomo and that impulsivity
would control me and I'd say i' jump in
and it would normally turn into a loss
because well it's a trade I just
shouldn't have been in anyway and of
course then that loses that's now two
losses on the day and I would then you
know be really frustrated sometimes it
would be you know worse than frustrated
you know there's going back to these
that there would be you know some days
it would turn into kind of hopelessness
or desperation you know if I'm kind of
on a losing streak it'd be just like oh
I just I keep doing this you know I'm
stuck in this cycle of constantly you
know blowing up my account or going on
these losing streaks and I can't seem to
make things work right and then
eventually after that you know some days
I would even Revenge trade you know I'd
frustrate and take another loss and
eventually though I would you know be
done for the day I'd be like okay I have
to be done I got to cut my losses things
aren't working out and I'd take a break
right and I would essentially reset your
normally I'd you know be done for the
day and I would reset and it would come
back as the next morning and I'd be good
to go you know I for me I can reset over
the night usually pretty well feel ref
ref freshed and kind of focused again
ready to trade and it would start that
same Loop over and over of that fear of
being wrong you know that a setup would
come and I get nervous and I'd skip the
trade and so this was kind of that cycle
that even though I had a good strategy I
would be stuck in and it would stop me
from becoming profitable and so let's
now talk about some actionable steps for
you to break out of the self-sabotage
Loop now the the first thing is through
this video you have already started to
build your awareness you need to go
through your trading and start to just
realize okay what are my emotions what
are they doing you know is it fomo that
is messing me up is it you know
nervousness is it greed go through and
think about your trades and make a list
of you know what's damaging your trading
and then you need to go in and say okay
how am I reacting to those emotions how
are they affecting my trading and how am
I I trading when I you know feel those
emotions am I impulsively jumping into a
trade or am I stopping and not getting
into a trade when I really should be
what you need to do is make a trading
journal and start to track and build
this list from your trading every time
you take a trade go in and write down
your emotions of what you felt when you
entered in on that trade or what you
felt when you were managing the trade
you know did you get out too early of
your trade because of fear you didn't
want to give up your profits or you let
the trade go on too long out of greed
and you gave up way more than you should
have because the you know the trade came
back against you and you know initially
you know you kind of saw the market
going up and you said okay I should
probably get out here but you know you
kind of got money eyes and the Euphoria
were like well what if it just keeps
going all the way up why would I want to
get out here but in reality the trade
you know you saw this spot you know
maybe it was that resistance Zone up
here and instead it It reversed right
there and you would have got out at the
tibity top and then the next stages of
that is well from understanding these
reactions and building your awareness
you'll start to realize okay well how do
I want to react based on that most of
the time it's you know the good default
is well I want to follow my plan you
know if my plan says to jump in on a
trade here I jump in no matter what I
feel if I'm scared that's okay I accept
it and I jump in on the trade that's how
you overcome you know your emotions
controlling you and impulsively you know
either jumping you in on a trade or
getting out too soon and then of the
last one is you start consistently
reacting correctly and what that kind of
looks like is you know here's your kind
of normal cycle of you know stuck in
that fear of being wrong you know for me
this was my cycle right instead I've
created a new cycle a better cycle that
essentially helps me be profitable and I
will jump in the tra consistently and
essentially it's I'll see a setup I'll
be kind of nervous that it's maybe not
going to work out you know that fear of
being wrong still comes up trading is
still intense even when you've done it
for years and years because you know
you're always increasing that size it's
always intense still right and so
instead though I'll feel that emotion
accept it and say well I want to follow
my plan anyway and I take the trade and
so I take the trade you know sometimes
it doesn't work out but a lot of the
time I have shifted my mindset to to say
well me jumping in on a trade that sets
up how I want that's a good trade it
doesn't matter if it wins or loses
instead a successful trade for me is if
it was a good trade setup if I jumped in
when I knew I should have and when the
patterns aligned with what I'm waiting
for and looking for every day and so
from there that helps me build
confidence because I traded how I want
to trade if you're doing this and
consistently executing through your
emotions and you're still you know not
profitable that just means you have to
go back through your trading journal and
tweak things that's where you know you
really start to narrow down what's
working and what isn't a lot of the time
you will find that if you can take out a
ton of the losing trades or you're ones
that consistently lose there's some
common denominator of why and if you
take a lot of those out and you can
through you know collecting that data
and reviewing your Journal it'll
drastically pump up your win rate and
how much profit you're making
consistently and so from there you know
it makes that new cycle of instead of
you know my muscle memory being to skip
the trade my now muscle memory and you
know kind of mental pattern is to take a
trade and I'm now essentially you could
say stuck in a cycle that is positively
impacting my trading versus one that's
negatively impacting my trading so
really take the time to think about this
and how it is is affecting you and your
trading because it's really going to
help you become consistently profitable
and make sure to get that list that I
put together of the 75 essential trading
lessons that I learned along the way of
breaking myself out of these two Loops
because it's really going to help
accelerate your process with that you
can get it either in the link in the
description of this video right now or
with a QR code right here and if you
want to learn more about my 30 minute
reversal strategy and the strategy I I
used and finally figured out that helped
me become consistently profitable with
only really 60 minutes a day in the
morning check out this video right here